michaela to this video playing blue jay
international master David Cummings from
from Canada I guess so the Trump okay
it's like 94 95 here this is an
interesting way to play recommend it in
borås a Brooks book beating d4 sideline
system the name of the book and very I
think a very good repertoire that he
said suggests them this is very easy to
play solution to the Trump okay c4 here
or c4 and then maybe g6 yeah maybe it's
not so great really I could also go a
night h5 yeah sorry okay
Knight h5 to try to get the bishop here
oh it's just killing me the bishop oh
that's a nice I'll take it and what now
Bishop g4 or is this too slow I wonder
if I should play Queen c7 maybe Queen c7
me it wasn't doing any good on b6 anyway
and a force hanging okay maybe
ninety-five Bishop f5 there is no
ticketing yeah I'm really not the whole
the whole play that I that I showed here
was very time-consuming Jim I guess I
need to take it okay I think I should be
okay really okay
castles won't be sure a fire first
maybe this first yeah that seems seem
safe
okay isn't playing Bishop d3 okay yeah
before maybe yeah just like that night
b3 and trying to get some play going on
the queenside I don't really think it
should be terribly dangerous for me
maybe even if I'm just gaining some
space here
yeah well I was sort of relying on the
fact that on the assumption that he
cannot take on a five and rb7 but maybe
he can and some but by now it's hard to
how to to deviate yeah just just being
terribly materialistic but probably
probably that's just a front
okay the good thing is that it's not
very a very problematic Allen if this
endgame should be perfectly fine I mean
how does he even keep the sheep on don't
really see how yeah that should that
should be okay yeah can give the check
but to age six maybe age six he still
has no way to protect c3 I don't see it
okay so he wants to give the check and
then hmm I can't play f6 as well now
maybe
check
night f7 looks like you know it looks
like a path journey with no return
ticket Knight f3 I'll take C 3 mm this
looks quite quite okay now I'd say okay
Wow I didn't just go to a c2 or not I
take a 5 takes f5 that's not bad
actually but I just want to take c3 with
no hassle whatsoever
like my king is a bit better and put in
danger in a way so I always need to be
need to be alert
but chief is really weakened to
structure terribly I mean something like
Knight f3 Bishop d6 is just winning this
pawn and I'm not even sure that this is
the best I mean maybe this also rook
takes c3 immediately
yeah I need some something good here
either otherwise some white is probably
toast yeah yeah as mentioned no return
ticket but is it is it in a way possible
to to word you use it to shop g6 loop h8
mate is one very very important idea
when I wonder about g5 maybe g5 tough
tough with one minute intending King g7
obviously rook h8 King g7 should win
material
hmm yes okay
he spotted his flyboarding spotted this
nice hmm
do I really need to take that would be a
wouldn't be so great
yeah I guess he's six is hanging I don't
see I can take c3 but I came and I
should I should speed up nearing the
king to defend e63 I can take anyway now
the good news is not getting any quicker
channel 57 I'm such an idiot
it had the simple idea and I've just
learned a classic the adjournment what
adjournment there is an old German for
in this five minute for check yeah I
know just to pawn down for zip and
piffle Wow could have taken like a
million times on c3 but I just didn't
very stupid
is very slow draw a third game drawn
yeah so this was very very very moronic
I just completely I didn't see any point
of Bishop b5 and it's just look at you
seven of this Slim Jim
I just need to take on c3 and nothing
special is happening I mean I have the
somewhat better pawn structure I'm not
sure how serious it really is but if
anything black is better of course but I
was just the total total did you see I
thought that just have this additional
defense if necessary and stuff I just
overlooked rook d7 check yeah it was it
was very very tricky
I had blunder this pawn on b7 but
there's really a case where white some
coordination and structure was so poor
that I have enough compensation this
move actually with hindsight I might
prefer f6 yeah this would have been
interesting just preventing the knight
from coming to e5 or g5 this would have
been interesting and he can play that
one though this this could be a problem
and quickly a five-year let's say let's
say I go here then there's f5 because if
I take this could be a balance with
service this is where okay can play here
and where now I will go here
it's very embarrassing yeah some
interesting technical points in the way
it has played I think I really really
was okay but g5 was even recommended by
the computer I wasn't sure about that
big stakes I know the comp just wants to
take on c3 immediately yeah maybe you
can do that I wasn't I wasn't so sure
because if you look at it here takes I
thought you would get to the pawn yeah
but maybe this is not even happening
something like that
yeah that's actually quite strong
threatening to win immediately and f3
for example it's um it's obviously good
for black not sure if I'm winning but
I'm certainly certainly much better yeah
very tricky and then I blunder to t7
check alright thanks for watching